bonjour germées sont d'autres bonjour
maurice bonjour tous les auditeurs et
auditrices de mardin premier président
du cros ma comité régional olympique et
sportif de la martinique germa son beau
le monde du sport est déçu les
dirigeants sont déçus les licenciés sont
déçus des parents de licenciés sont en
colère car nos infrastructures se
dérègle de plus en plus nous assisterons
cela à cela longtemps sans pouvoir y
faire quelque chose même si lewis un
constat douloureux d'autant que je
pourrai commencer par cela depuis des
années on ne lui donnerait pas d'année
la marine et quai des antilles
singulièrement sensible fournissent les
équipes de france et nous fournissons
des résultat qui sont olympiques
mondiaux nationaux européens et cetera
donc c'est quand même désolant c'est
vrai que ce constat est fait clairement
dans les chiffres des statistiques
montrent que nous sommes en retard de
cette bon sens c'est-à-dire gloria 40
installations dans une conurbation et ne
je dirais ne municipalité en métropole
il y en a vingt ici donc on a un grand
retard d'où l'idée d'un plan de
rattrapage un instrument qui n'a ne
semble pas ce qu'on voit est poursuivi
par ce qu'il y a un an tout juste
patrick kanner alors ministre de la
ville de la jeunesse et des sports était
ici même à votre place et nous annonçait
des fonds pour rénover des équipements
entre autres c'est vrai donc il y avait
en avant qu'un sur quatre fois 20
millions sur quatre ans malheureusement
l'un de l'autre mais il faudra pour
l'enfant dormait alors ça faisait en
réalité ça devenait peau de chagrin
quand on regarde et un petit peu partout
mais c'était déjà un effort consenti
aujourd'hui c'est quand même une équipe
d'un fan mandat vous savez que les
élections sont passées par là
aujourd'hui nous avons nous sommes très
proches de la ministre laura flessel
pouvoir
si nous pouvons maintenir mais nous
savons d'ores et déjà que les budgets
avec la crise économique le contexte
économique celui-là on n'en parle plus
non je ne dirais pas cela nous sommes en
train de défendre l'idée que ce plat est
annoncée devrait
poursuit j'ai l'impression que tu as des
inscrits me battre ou suivent lorsqu'un
ministre signe un document on peut pas
revenir là dessus comme ça c'est ce qui
va se passer concernant nos équipements
je ne peux pas rentrer dans les détails
de cette gouvernance mais ministériel et
oeuvres de retard mais nous sommes là
nous pour revendiquer nounou droit c'est
vrai vous avez raison il ya eu un
engagement moral et un engagement écrit
nous allons tenter de le poursuivre et
demandé à la nouvelle équipe et celle de
laura flessel deux beaux-fils jugé cet
avantage là connaître avant qu'elle soit
nommée donc j'espérais de jouer de toute
mon influence pour essayer de voir
comment nous pouvons je dirais
poursuivre je dirais une rénovation
indispensable aux installations qui sont
vraiment dans un état déploie alors
quels sont les équipements qui souffre
le plus en martinique ce sont les sièges
sont les listes à dassault c'est quoi
exactement peu partout dans des shows
vers la maison du spo rayon d'un
difficulté rassurons nous n'hébergeons
que 20 lits gallo qu'on en a 60 on un
projet de novation la prime c'est un
merveilleux provisionnel très performant
jérôme isambart qui a fait un grand
projet nous sommes en cours mais avec la
crise les projets je dirais qu'il ya des
priorités
le stade de dillon n'est pas aux normes
quand vous allez au françois et des
difficultés liées à chine mérite
innovation bon il ya du colmatage même
en tout dont nous sommes d'abord entré
sur la rénovation sur la
maintenance des installations qui ne ce
qui n'est pas forcément assuré qui
coûtait qui coûte aux est du flat
entendu entendu dans dans les tribunes
aux abords de cfa structures sportives
mais quelles sont ses ingénieurs qui
conçoivent ce type d'équipement
lorsqu'on voit qu'à peine crier ça coule
déjà que les licenciés par exemple après
midi joue avec souley qui tombe
directement dans les yeux il ya problème
dégénéré
la fabrication de ces équipements dignes
de langnau fondamental au delà du
problème de la crise que je dis je
revendique le fait que les sports en
martinique et le sporting est né à trop
fourni aux équipes pour on n'est pas
tous le verdissement ça c'est un premier
plan fondamental qui doit être posée qui
a deux peuples amis militants que je
poursuis depuis depuis que je pense
riverains quant au delà tsai un point
quand vous dites d'ingénierie nous
construisons installations sportives un
peu çà et là au bonheur de la chasse des
budgets des conjonctures politiques
alors nous sommes le communiqué
précisant l'heure dans une chatte
apolitique tu as dit que nous ne faisons
nous ne montons pas une scène politique
politicienne gens mais nous avons des
positionnements évidemment cléa qui ont
des fois des incidences politiques bien
ceci étant dit le problème est le
suivant que doit concevoir un équipement
vous demande de vous projeter 20 30 ans
voire plus en avant que sera le monde
cynique sportif de demain que doit
apporter le sport à la martinique
c'est toute cette réflexion et quand
autant la pause et l'idée du sport
industrie c'était de dire que quand on
est en crise le sport doit survivre par
le fait qu'il démontre qu'il est utile à
la société et pour être utile à
l'enquêté
il faut des études vous savoir que
devons-nous faire je crois un exemple
très concret vous ne pas être trop long
aujourd'hui nous avons des poèmes de
maladies chroniques et le point de santé
dont nous devons développer toute forme
de pratique de masse qui permettent à la
population d'aller mieux ça et dui des
investitures et des investissements clés
nous avons un problème des sections de
jeunes dans notre jeunesse dans les
quartiers saint denis aussi des
instruments de bord ce mythe est léger
mais équipe et qu'on a beaucoup de thé
dans des études mais ce que je reviens
lâché sur me vestiaires mais je reviens
à ma question germées sont beaux comment
peut-on concevoir konaré qu'un
équipement à peine livré fuient déjà
cool déjà que
quel à disposition de la salle fait dans
peut pas le faire parce qu'il ya trop de
vent que le la trajectoire du ballon et
modifié à cause du vent pour que le
soleil arrive dans les yeux ça c'est le
deuxième problème je dis je termine le
premier point en disant qu' il quelle
gouvernance qui décide
parce que il est supposé que le croc
c'est d'ailleurs dans les statuts
nouveau ce sera bientôt les nouveaux
statuts le prg aux produits et aux
intestins port projet sportif
territorial qui donne une direction à
toutes les institutions de là où on va
il faut ces moyens forcément une charge
de 10 points si nous voulons une
martinique de santé nous devons loyauté
si nous devons martinique y compris
désertion devons orienter nos structures
ont ils de faire de grandes fondations à
lens plutôt sus de la proximité à ayant
déjà qu'on vous dit de l'ingénierie une
idée de ce que nous voulons de la
martinique de demain et qu'est ce que le
pouce pop ramener notre société tout ça
c'est très dit qu'un de vos costumes
foire et et lydie même si c'est
difficile à gommer que chaque maire pour
à fait à sa piscine ou son stade de
l'actualisation de ses yeux sa
population avant les élections et que le
budget arrive temps en temps il faut se
projeter dans une programmation
sérieusement comment je suis assis avec
voit la mutualisation des fonctions
projet cohérent utilisation d aider des
projets d infrastructure maintenant mais
quand même technique ya un problème dans
la conception sa déco joug d'une somme
autres dont nous nous fournir de 2,2 de
nous entourer de spécialistes techniques
qui sont des sportives aussi et qui
puisse aller de l'avant
je prends l'exemple les 110 m haies ce
qui a été conçue certainement il ya eu
beaucoup d'efforts exclusivité du spa
voilà si tu martinique et du sport où il
ya effectivement quelques je dirais
néfastes culture qui n'était pas
forcément penser correctement irritation
des baskets jules attirer les pandores
exactement dans la précipitation souvent
on oublie de consulter des spécialistes
nous avons des spécialistes ici et
des grands spécialistes qui peuvent
faire appel aux fédérations lorsqu'on
consulte du mans j'appelle les
institutions a fait appel au moins
sportifs qui connaissent les normes et
qui savent comment je dirais donner les
conseils qu'il faut pour éviter des
erreurs de conception
quand vous disiez n'était vingtaine is
orientées avec le soleil op mes yeux et
c'est bon ce sont des ddd des héros
qu'il faut maintenant éviter la maison
bojan la sombre lorsque les
collectivités qui qui voient leur budget
s'amenuisent il lorsque les promesses
gouvernementales ne sont pas tenues
quelles sont les alternatives est ce
qu'on doit se trouver vers de se tourner
vers le privé qui est de moins en moins
d'argent puisque notre population notre
démographie baisse leur chiffre
d'affaires mais aussi dont ils n'ont
plus d'argent pour mettre dans le milieu
sportif
effectivement tableau très spécial très
pessimiste mais il faut rester je dirais
vaillant et combatif laurence menti
c'est beaucoup de bénévoles passionnés
il continue à y croire
comment trouver des moyens économiques
c'est vrai que le public c'est difficile
puissance publique difficile le privé
difficile donc ya pas tellement la
tunisie par contre quelques réflexions
un thème les installations des collèges
qui sont inutilisés des lycées yema
comme un beau monde qui sont fermés à
madame trimestre de l'éclairage à la
structure de classe et ce serait déjà
moins cher vous déclinez d'équipé de
l'ouvrir la porte arrière pour pouvoir
déjà bénéficié de ce tome d'installation
m gardiens qui sera là pourrait ouvrir
et fermer
oui il ya tous et tout mais ça peut-être
créé deux ans qu'il n'ya pas de petit
copain de la jeune fille qui vient
s'entraîner pour le handball ne traite
pas l'intérieur du collège j à tout ça à
dire ça comme ça mais je dis on n'a rien
sans peine et je veux dire que l'idée
que de mutualiser des installations y en
a qui sont à l'abandon qu'il faut
reprendre venir là je crois qu'il faut
vraiment poser une réflexion pas
forcément romain rattrapage
d'équipements c'est clair on a aussi des
équipements dans notre port
d'équipements toute une région il ya
déjà eu des études comment exploiter au
mieux en exploitant des écoles en
exploitant c'est un enjeu peau pour
faire au mieux mais on fera entendre la
voix du sport martiniquais notamment à
l'occasion des assises de l'autre mère
qui commenceront très bientôt merci
jamais son bout d'un moment on rappelle
que vous êtes le président du cros
comité régional olympique et sportif de
la martinique
[Musique]